I'm here with Sunil Veera mantri the
stepfather of a coruña camera Oh and one
of his most loyal supporters
Sunil tell us a little bit about your
role as a stepfather for hikaru coming
up how did you recognize the talent I
wish I knew
but around the age of 10 he just took
off and then there was no stopping him
so you know I like to think I did
something special but I don't really
think so I think it was really him do
you still get involved into his career
actively the train him at all or do you
just go to tournaments and and and be as
a moral support for him
yeah I'm mainly in the position of moral
support although I do give him some
advice so that's really my involvement
one thing that people might not know is
that you were actively involved in
creating this tournament the single cup
tell us more about that yes indeed so
joy and Tony and Jeannie talking one day
and we were saying you know there's
nothing named after X and we really
needed something so let's create
something called this thing filled cup
so the idea at the time was to do a six
play a double round-robin and I was
going to Norway for the Norway chess
tournament so I was entrusted with
speaking to people and setting this up
so when I got to know me though the
first person I spoke to was live Aronian
and because Magnus would not play or
would prefer to play if Liv was playing
so I spoke to live and they've said
there's no way so no it's not gonna work
double you know and and so I looked at
live schedule and I said okay give me
your dates he said this is what I have
so on the spur of the moment I changed
the tournament myself without calling
st. Louis and I said okay it's going to
be a four round double round-robin four
player double round-robin
you know and that'll fit in the dates
will that work he said yes so I said
okay you're on so then I called Espen
got ahold of Magnus and I called San
Luis and said I just changed a
tournament it is now the top two in the
world versus the top two in the u.s. so
Sakarya angada and that's how we started
did you envision
that this is going to be one of the
biggest events in the world right now we
have the top 10 chess players on the
planet actively playing in this
tournament right now mastics to see you
know and yes we did have an idea it
would evolve into that but we had to
start somewhere and so you know getting
that first tournament off the ground was
the hardest thing to do and you're also
the executive director of the National
scholastic chair Foundation also the
culture of the Scholastic Council of the
US just tell us a little bit more about
that and how is your involvement playing
out so I am very involved in trying to
popularize stress and you know we are
always looking at you know at ways to do
it and and I think the one thing that we
have not succeeded in doing is creating
a value proposition that all parents
understand that hey it's good for my kid
to play chess right there is a benefit
to this if we can get parents buying
into this that's the first step you know
we have to be able to create that right
secondly we have to actually enlist the
parents support in helping teach the
kids and that's why for example that
recent booklet that dr. Jeanne
Sinquefield put out you know learn to
read and write chess yes this one I
think something like this that can be
made available at very low cost if at no
cost at all to parents we'll get them
involved you see and that becomes part
of the process thirdly you need to get
chess as a curricular subject in schools
and you know that's a little harder to
do but certainly in kindergarten through
second grade every single kid should
have an exposure to chess and but it
requires a different kind of teaching
because you are not teaching necessarily
to produce chess players but for other
benefits and so for example you know in
those grades you should tie it into
social emotional learning and meet the
standards that you know there are
prescribed so so this is very important
and lastly I would say what you're doing
here in st. Louis which is having the
the best of the best come and play so
that you can try to create role models
you know for the young people so they
can see you know Fabiano Khurana
Dakara Nakamura and then they are very
successful and they would aspire to be
something like this so this these
tournaments fill that role beautifully
and you were a lot of hats and you're
you are also an author tell us a bit
about that and actually we have one of
your books
which was aired last year if I'm not
mistaken talk about this a little bit
and how does this tie into the social
studies and chess so this book was
published last year and the reason I
published it was because I wanted to
show regular educators that there's an
intersection between normal academic
subjects and chess you see because I
think that actually helps to get just
into the curriculum and to me the most
obvious first step was to talk about
chess and history you know it has a
great history in fact question you know
the chess board right here in the center
of the bird on the cover this belonged
to King Charles the first of England and
Charles was deposed and eventually
executed when Charles was led to his
execution he took two things with him in
one hand he had a Bible and in the other
hand and in 2004 you were the chest
educator of the year I think you
received that the word at University of
Texas at Dallas which is a my alma mater
and also I'm involved in college trust
what can we tell us about college trust
how can we improve the experience of the
chess players coming to compete and be
professional athletes on a collegiate
team yes so now you know we are getting
increasing involvement in college I know
you yourself are starting a program in
Mizzou I think that this is a very
important step I don't understand why we
have so many high school players and at
the scholastic level and they all
stopped playing when they go to college
so creating more chess club's
and giving them opportunities to pursue
it even you know at a less competitive
level I think is extremely important
well Sunil thank you very much for
taking the time to speak with us and
share your ideas and
I'm sure we'll see you around because
you were here with Hikaru of course
watching his games and suffering
alongside him thank you very much to him